welcome to cloud minute today I'm going
to show you a bit about stack driver
error reporting like most folks i
occasionally ship code that has bugs in
it luckily error reporting can help me
out so i just got an email telling me
that there's a new error in my app
engine app i deployed a couple minutes
ago so the air is probably related it
looks like there's a division by zero
are that's causing a 500 response i can
go to the cloud console to get more
details
once on the console I can see that this
error has happened nine times and it's
been seen multiple versions of my
application you can see the status that
it's causing and can also see when the r
was first seen and when it was last seen
if i scroll down a little bit there's
some samples of the error and include a
stack trace and some additional
information that might be helpful for
debugging usually in my process at this
point I'd enter a bug and once I do that
I can link a bug to this error by
clicking this button I hope error
reporting is able to help you fix
application errors quickly